hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
one of our readers Jenna who's asking me
about how to set pricing as a freelance
consultant so her question is hi yes as
a freelancer how does one know if
they're charging too much Jenna so
general couple things help you out here
first off most entrepreneurs actually
under priced themselves so we could all
charge a lot more of our services and
usually get it from the client but we
feel like we're charging too much and
we're worried we were we might lose a
client so we typically under charge for
our services but it can be a really
difficult question how does that your
price is a challenge that a lot of
entrepreneurs face so somebody needs to
help you up first off when you're when
you're just launching the business
usually what you do is you look at you
know what are your competitors charging
and also how much time does it actually
take you so we look at what it costs you
instead of the value that necessarily
brings a customer you look more the cost
side of the equation and you want to
make sure you competitive and that you
know you're not losing money and you're
able to earn a living the next thing I
would encourage you to do is when you do
get relationships with customers try to
add much value as you can into that
relationship you want to try to make
yourself stand up to all the other
freelancers who do the exact same thing
as you so hook example from my
experience one of the things I got hired
to do was create content for brands who
try to target entrepreneurs so might
write a blog post for them for example
so they say can you please write a 305 /
that word blog post on our site and
that's what I got paid to do and so I
would do that gladly but that always go
way beyond what they expected so I would
write a 500-word code so 300 word post i
wrote a thousand-word post or 1500 work
post and then i wouldn't just rely on
them to you know posted up on there's
heaven promoter I would also actively
market it so I put into my newsletter
list I
talk about over my youtube channel a
tweet about my facebook and drive a lot
of interest in it and what that does is
help separate me from every other
freelance it really might have hired to
create the same 300 to 500 word article
for them so I'm going to get more
referrals and get more business but my
business is going to grow and I'm going
to be able to increase my price so same
thing for you look at whatever service
you're offering and how can you go just
way beyond their expectations give them
way more than a they thought that we're
going to get and you're going to find
the next thing they have a project
they're going to come back to you
because they love what you're doing
they're going to refer lots of new
business to you and that's your schedule
gets filled up as a freelancer you only
have so much time of the day because you
know that's basically selling with your
time as it time since you get chewed up
you can start increasing the prices and
you know if you if you lose a client
because they can't afford it that's fine
because you're you're booked up you're
growing your company so once that
momentum takes over and people start
buying from you again and referring
business to you because of the great
series you provided you're going to
slowly see that you're able to increase
those prices as you go along so I hope
that helps Jenna if you guys liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below I
also like to hear what your experiences
are the pricing if you want to leave a
feedback below this video with the
comment and state to the next episode